[Music]
what up
mike young here detroit native living in
la
16 years comedian writer
director directed two movies nobody
really saw
that's okay maybe i'll get to direct
another one
everybody in la's got a film fun right
now priority number one
get a new hour of material and do a
special
that's all we want is comedians is a
special that's it
right now i'm going on stage in 15
minutes
bam how you doing man mike young come on
in 15 just want to rest up
you might want to check in right on the
front over there brother oh no man i'm a
regular here i'm on the wall between
sega and kinison
mike young who the [ __ ] is mike young
being single is exhausting you got to be
in physical shape mental shape verbal
condition
you got to talk there's
[ __ ] words everywhere
i got to get a girlfriend just so i
could shut up again
i cannot wait to be quiet and
competition is real out there in the
streets
it's real guys are out there in tight
shirts and hair gel everywhere
me and this one guy were talking to the
same girl he tried to hit her with like
an athletic achievement and a hand touch
i had to come back strong with a
sensitive story and a back rub i don't
play games
then he tried to come out like a
business that was going to make millions
i had to go right to a lie i'm like my
family invented the table
you ever heard of the table bro it's
kind of a big item player
yeah i'm mike table google me walk away
now it's over
hi paul texted and wanted to know what
time basketball was and i think your mom
called but it just at home
babe you can't check my text that's
invasive you can have sex with me but i
can't check your phone
those two things have nothing to do with
each other they do to me
don't worry mike i'm not gonna like me
to you or anything oh my god how could
you even say something like that
we had a great night a great consensual
night two pillows each
both slept great i got you water twice
in the middle of the night
hot coffee in the morning
i love the songs
i cannot hear that song right now i know
you dated this girl but
how what do you mean how
you dated caroline and you wear reading
glasses and you drive a honda accord
honda accords motor trend car of the
year three years running
you have major trust issues didn't we
talk about this last night
we just met last night
[Music]
two kinds of girls over 30 under 30.
there is a distinct difference
over 30 they got their [ __ ] figured out
yeah
they're here talking
[Applause]
they know what they want all right if
there's a one-night stand it was a
one-night stand for her too she didn't
want to be there either
she's a grown woman bro you got used all
right you got used
it happens every now and then you will
get used here's a hint fellas any time
everything you say works it's not you
just a little tip from single mike
it's a grown woman she will tuck you in
like a child and leave with carrie out
she doesn't care
you looked up she was in your toaster
oven making a chicken quesadilla
you didn't even know you had chicken
not under 30 oh young girls they'll stay
for the weekend they don't give a [ __ ]
ah they move right in they don't leave
they act like their parents dropped them
off for a slumber party
it's 12 o'clock in the afternoon like
what's for lunch
a taxi sandwich
you have to go a you don't live here
burrito is what we're having today
all right you're having an uber salad
uber salad
little young girls they got so much
energy too under 30
energy for days all they wanted let's go
to the after party
i'm exhausted is anybody tired
i'm not going to the after party unless
there's soup
how good is soup it's like you're
already in bed i love a good soup
if there's french onion soup i'll eat
your [ __ ] and call your uncle
it's the best soup i ever had who makes
that soup
i'll eat the cheese and throw out the
soup i'll sleep in that soup
under 30. they want to play fight i
don't want to play fight i'm a grown man
all right don't put me in a headlock you
just pinched a nerve that [ __ ] hurts
yeah now i'm hurt i got a softball game
thursday my team needs me
i'm a three-time all-star you don't just
put me out of the game
punch me in the stomach that's how
houdini died you could kill somebody
don't just punch people when they're not
looking
under 30. even in bed women get better
as they get older
these younger girls they're doing [ __ ]
they see on the internet i don't even
know what these moves are
i i can't keep up i don't know your move
this girl's crawling on the edge of the
bed
i was like yo did you lose your wallet
where are you going
what are you doing in my hallway this
doesn't even make sense
none of this is fun for me come back
[ __ ] it get the mail then come back
you work for me now
i don't know what these moves are these
young girls man they grew up on internet
porn
that's not real all right it's not real
you don't have to spit everywhere quit
spitting
it's not a spitfest you're drooling like
a kid
all right relax stop it
over 30 they just got their [ __ ]
together you know what i mean not afraid
to pull out toys in the bedroom
they'll pull them out right there they
don't care i was with one girl she had a
whole drawer full of [ __ ] i panicked
yeah i was involved in a threesome i was
the only human being
i didn't know what to do all right i was
in the corner with a remote control car
what am i even doing here
she had real toys she's like let's do it
again i'm like let me finish my lego
castle
it's a wrap man i'm done the single
life's gonna kill me whoa
slow down all right you gotta stay
unsettled
i'll be the settled guy if you settle
down and i don't have any stories and i
need them to live through it
any chance your guys are gonna get the
money for my movie oh yeah it's a lock i
mean these guys have to make twelve five
hundred thousand dollar movies by the
end of the
year i would love to be one of those
movies i know can they get me a friend
pass on raya you verified
i don't even know what that means well
then you got to be rich or famous is
there a section for potential
no [ __ ] briah who wants to go on a site
with nothing but beautiful girls my next
relationship i gotta quit mistaking
crazy for interesting
every guy's done it oh you're so
spontaneous and full of life this girl's
the life of the party look at her go
six weeks in wow you're bipolar this is
real [ __ ]
this is so real you don't like me i like
all the different use bring back sunday
sunday just reads and relaxes tuesday
will kill you on a wednesday
but i'm not i'm done with fast explosive
relationships
we've all had though you ever had one of
those where you do everything in a week
and you never talk again
just do it all right away right we met
we fought we had great sex i got your
brother a job we never talked again
we did it all i talked to my doctor
i got low tea it's real
you don't have low tea bob you got a low
tea life you got the perfect amount of
tea for your life
you're married to a great girl you stay
inside most of your life
you don't want my tea give me the antler
mike i know you got it
i'm not giving you the antler bob this
is what kept barry bonds out of the hall
of fame
trust me this is what pro athletes are
on so why are you on it
because being single in la is a pro
sport
give me the [ __ ] antler mike all
right bob
two squirts only on the tone
mike pop to the three-point line and
i'll kick it out
guys when i go down low find me i'm just
gonna shoot it ah
don't shoot it got it bobby all right
pressman let me ask you a question how
does it feel to take someone's idea
and just sell it to a studio and make a
[ __ ] fortune and you don't even reach
out
i should take your shaved head and shave
it again because you know what
i can do any [ __ ] thing i want
because that's what i can do
i didn't steal your idea bob i was
working on naked and afraid for years
before we even met
hey we had naked you added afraid
and sold it i'm your dentist bob the
show was a fluke i just saw your wife in
the office on thursday
yes i know she came home swollen you
molar [ __ ]
she looks like a sad crying blowfish
married friends versus single
all right married friends do not have my
immune system you can't do what i do
okay you got kids your kid walks in
sneezes your whole family's a mess for a
month
i make out with a stripper on a
wednesday just to clear my sinuses
i'm like a walking z-pack i couldn't
catch a cold if i wanted one
i couldn't catch i'm getting older but
i'm staying young
i'm keeping it young i'm in a softball
league hockey league basketball league
yeah i can't even work i got an 80 game
season
i got no time to work right now are you
crazy playoffs are coming don't [ __ ]
around
we got to get that championship this
year it's probably not going to happen
my team's 0 and 8.
we're terrible we're like the bad news
bears before they went to rehab
i got a right fielder hooked on diet
pills he's just shaking in the outfield
pulled a hamstring without even moving
ow
i got a center fielder so stoned he's
like wow who cuts all this grass
my first baseman thinks he's good he's
horrible i should be pitching
you should be home you're terrible
and he brings his girl to every game why
do you bring your girl when you're
terrible
that's like the opposite of showing off
bro she's gonna [ __ ] the shortstop by
accident
quit bringing your girl
i got that one guy best dressed worst
athlete don't you love him guys got 500
worth of [ __ ] on couldn't catch a beach
ball
looks amazing just comes out smooth
gets the ball again
but you keep him on the team because his
dad owns a sporting goods store
gotta get free [ __ ] my captain's still
yelling at us you ever get yelled at as
an adult on a team
it's a little uncomfortable where is
your speed mike
in high school pete
who am i kidding i'm getting older i'm
pulling muscles doing nothing
you ever yawn and get stuck
what the hell is going on in the facial
area am i
just like i have a small section of my
head's dehydrated what is happening
right here
you're like oh
ah
i was a kid i could play street football
for 10 hours bounce off a car fender i
was fine
yesterday i pulled a neck muscle
ordering food and looking left
i was like yeah let me get it oh that's
got to be something serious hold on one
sec bro
hold on one sec no seriously it's just
in my lung area
it's floating in a rib i'll be fine just
give me a second
my boy's like what'd you do i'm like oh
[ __ ] i talked and turned
i can't talk it turn he knew he's like
don't do that bro you gotta pause you
know superhero
are you crazy there's air involved man
wake up
can't just have run out sentences
what's up mike young jason what up just
living what's happening
all right here's the deal my boy paul's
got two hedge fund guys out of new york
they read my script they love the movie
they say they want to fund the movie and
maybe let me direct it
they've got to make 12 500 000 films
this year
for some reason they have to spend the
money i don't know some kind of tax code
rich people [ __ ] will you please give
them a call you know i will baby
look if they got real money put you in a
three picture deal and slide my life
story right inside that [ __ ] you
know there's some interesting [ __ ]
before i manage it mike young
my life would make a hell of a movie
well that's great but can we work on
making my movie first
yeah man you didn't even need to ask
that [ __ ] well i feel like i do i wish i
didn't but i do
i'll talk to you later man i'll see you
this week hey listen you got to swing by
the new crib
you're going to love that [ __ ]
all right i'll talk to you later
just [ __ ] [ __ ] bro one day she's
into me the next day radio
silence things were going great i don't
think they were ever going great stevie
you're a disaster right now do yourself
a favor go off the grid for six days and
on day seven she'll wake up calling you
out of nowhere why seven days
women have a clock in their head they
don't hear from you for six days they
wake up day seven everybody gets a phone
call
let's do the seven day thing in like
seven days because
i told her we're gonna help her set up a
birthday party so you're in
absolutely not but maybe
[Music]
you ever look at your friends and go why
are we still hanging out
this table's gotta be thinking that [ __ ]
right now
this poor guy hasn't even looked over
just wondering how you got here
i got one friend so lazy his goal is for
me to make it that's a bad goal
i can't be your goal bro hello
well i [ __ ] a rapper in my parents
living room last night and you know what
i'm 100 on board with it
i need a shot yo put your [ __ ] on
timeout heather seriously you're going
to get killed out there on the streets
be careful
women are the new men i met one girl she
was married dating and sort of seeing
somebody
good for her i'd love to meet her you
know what
i'm having a great time for your
information my divorce is final
i haven't felt this free in years and i
think i might really like this devontae
guy
he's a beautiful person he's a poet it's
[ __ ] hot really what happened to you
just dating dudes around here
oh oh my dick moved to venice that's
literally the greatest sentence i've
ever heard in my life
i'm gonna write that down absolutely
yeah no straight white hedge fund dick
is worth traffic on the 10.
i'll write that down too oh do you want
to come to the studio with me
devante is recording a new song he wants
me to hear it i love the studio are you
kidding me
you can't go there by yourself you look
like you're made out of a fendi bag you
know i've been thinking about saturday
night
liz has a friend i think she's a single
mom so we'll probably better off doing
like a low-key dinner and then we'll
turn it up a notch hell no bro single
moms don't want fun and food single moms
want cocaine and house music
cocaine you know how to get cocaine
yeah i don't do cocaine but i can get
cocaine i used to open for ron white
dave chappelle mike epps i can get you
cocaine weed and a gun
thursday at noon i got friends going
through divorce if you're going through
it i'm sorry it's ugly
you know what i mean but quit trying to
hang out with me
you're embarrassing me all right quit
trying to hang out with single mike
it's making me you know what i mean you
don't have my immune system yet
you don't just go from divorce to single
all right you got to stretch out for a
month
yeah you got a weak system okay you got
kids your kid walks in sneezes your
whole family's a mess for a week
i make out with a stripper on a
wednesday just to clear my sinuses
i'm disgusting i'm like a walking z-pack
right now
i can't even catch a cold i'm not proud
of it i'm going through a phase
married friends stop your vicarious
living
all right it's killing me it's stressing
me out and i don't need your secrets
that's too many secrets i'm not a vault
not
a vault all right [ __ ] work on that bit
my divorce friends coming to hang out at
the club just
what are you doing take a minute you
know what i mean showing girls pictures
of your kids soccer team
what's wrong with you bro this girl is
26 years old break out the cocaine and
tell a lie
she does not want to see the picture of
the kid's soccer team
she was on that team four years ago
she's in the picture what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
stop it you're embarrassing everybody
the divorce guys are depressing to watch
especially divorced guys with money you
see a divorce ever see a divorced rich
guy
they're a mess that's where grab the
[ __ ] came from
yeah i don't care what side you're on it
doesn't matter grabbing the [ __ ] was
never the thing
you know what i mean fellas you don't
grab the [ __ ] you put your hand on the
thigh and say a prayer
see what happens say a line prayer
next week i'm going to vegas for a
bachelor party that should be terrible
yeah if you clap for vegas that means
you've been once
that is the worst place in the world oh
you think you have fun right but then
you get to vegas
every vegas trip is the same you're like
yeah we're going to vegas we're going to
make money we're going to meet girls
eight hours into day one yo bro give me
the hell out of here right now
i don't even care how i get home i'll
hitchhike where you going arizona drop
me off i'll start a candle company
i'll start my whole life over i've never
been this suicidal before
you go to vegas you lose money you ever
lose money start rationalizing the trip
trying to pretend you're even
you start counting [ __ ] up it doesn't
matter
no bro i'm even i got a free club
sandwich and i swam
i'm killing it bro i saw white tigers
that's gonna be two grand i'm actually
up fifteen hundred dollars
i went to the mirage it's like a jungle
what's africa twenty thousand
bro i am killing it this trip it's
depressing losing money
there's always a guy at the table that
wants to give you advice that you didn't
even ask for
you're just thinking out loud you're
like oh should i hit the six against the
eight
well you got nothing to lose and then
you lose i've never seen that before
that's incredible how does it happen
my detroit criminal mind kicks in i'm
like i'm gonna [ __ ] snatch this guy's
chips
and they party hard in vegas yeah they
party too hard any time it's
5am and you see a 70 year old man
moonwalking go home bro
go home you guys having more fun than
everybody live your life junior wow
when you're single everybody trust you
trust somebody else as soon as you tell
me a secret my first thought is
who can i tell i can't wait to tell
somebody
yo what's going on honey mikey mikey
mike have you seen the new girl upstairs
in a part before b
no who is it yeah i can't really get
into it right
building policy i could fight all that
[ __ ] right but she used to be an adult
film actress
now she's transitioning into real estate
that's an amazing transition but she
also still dabbles oh you don't just
dabble there man there's no half
dabbling in that she still dabbles you
that's a tough devil and again i can't
say anything because of boom policy but
i fixed the washer and dryer the other
day and there was sex toys everywhere
wow man that's an incredible story do me
a favor behind me while i have you here
can you please just check my washing
machine
take a quick look at it let's make it a
weird sound yeah
yeah not not now i'll i'll stop back
later though you got your work gloves
man yeah no i'll be back
i'll be back you know what i say love
the flaws just accept each other's flaws
you'll be good
you know what i mean fellas just look at
your girl like oh babe that's so cute
how you yelling me about [ __ ] that never
happened
so adorable keep losing your keys i'm
going to hold you forever
ah you're so cute leave the oven on
again kill the whole family i want to
hold you come here you're so pretty
[Music]
what's up mike young look at you working
from home now huh
[ __ ] yeah you wanna take shoes off
yeah man every day is casual tuesday
ain't gotta worry about nobody trying to
steal my parking space it's [ __ ]
quiet
save a [ __ ] ton on gas and ain't gonna
worry about other managers trying to
steal my [ __ ] clients what's
happening man
let's see you guys good man i'm good how
you doing i'm good i'm good yo did you
talk to paul are those guys getting the
money for the movie what do you think is
it gonna happen
did you talk to him subsidy hey sit down
man
relax ah
no i'm gonna slowplay him
let him call me a few more times make
him hungry let me know you're busy
but i'm not busy i'm the opposite of
busy i don't want a slow play i need a
quick play
all right reverse psychology not the
move on this one i got something else i
want to put you down with
hear me out so i sold the show
to the discovery channel you sold a show
how did you sell a show
you're a manager you know i love old
cars right
yeah but i think we're way off track
right now man did you know that in 1983
corvette didn't make a car what about my
career
the plan's already laid just just hear
me out right dig it
so i tell these cats what if we designed
an 83 vet
auction went off for charity every week
[ __ ] gets a car
and his life together it's like a
make-a-wish for car lovers [ __ ]
will love that [ __ ]
what do you think they said they want me
to direct that's a done deal won't we
get going baby
they said they want the show and they
want me
to host that [ __ ]
so you're telling me that my manager is
hosting a show that he also created
god is good mike young is nobody happy
with where they are in life
my doctor wants to be an actor my waiter
wants to be a screenwriter and my
manager wants to do everything except
manage me
if my doctor's too busy thinking about
his one-man show i could be dead
i quit drinking for a year i'm back
i'm back
that's right what a stupid year
i remember the whole year
you don't need to remember a whole year
you know what i mean there's no reason
for it
i got regrets you know what i mean i
don't even remember my regrets
i'm not one of these people that's like
i got no regrets bro i can live life
you got no regrets that just means
you're an
i got [ __ ] you ever noticed the more
expensive the alcohol the cooler the
buzz
i drank hennessy i thought i was an 82
year old black jazz musician
i started giving advice for no reason i
was like you got to work hard junior
ain't no shortcuts in life playboy
but then you drink cheap [ __ ] like wild
turkey like i'm gonna shoot a relative
you don't talk to me like that at a
family function
i put this picnic on
and then you drink jack daniels you ever
drink whiskey some friend has an
emotional outburst for no reason
mike i've known you 20 years bro i kill
for you bro
you don't have to i want to i'm tired of
waiting
your father was a good man you're like
he's not even dead
he doesn't even care they talk about
events that didn't happen ninth grade
football we were in the trenches
together
together mike i'm like i didn't make
that team
he gets upset [ __ ] that coach you were
gifted
you were a true talent we're in the club
2 a.m she trying to [ __ ] 3 a.m
i beat it up 4 a.m back to the club
they see the blue chad they know i'm
terrified but let me clarify [ __ ] know
i'm crucified
i'm in another
yo you sound great man in the pocket
message
clear really saying something appreciate
that man i appreciate that
i grew up on hip-hop just saying jam
master j was a friend of mine
oh jim master chair stove jimmy
jam master jay damn how old are you
i met him when i was a kid mike used to
rap my face
is younger than my chest is my face
is younger than my chest is my face is
younger than my chest is
i'm old and i'm young all at the same
time
right for real yeah man detroit 99
[ __ ] was real seven mile if she's in her
20s take it down with the one
if she's in her 30s bringing it up with
a two
if she's in the 40s i don't even touch
it
you could get lost in the jungle
what happened to the group ah a fight
broke out in a club scared my dj into
doing bar mitzvahs
yeah [ __ ] all right also my ex used to
record here
who's that carol lane oh
carol lane oh [ __ ]
yeah why is everyone so shocked that
that was my ex am i uglier than i think
nah one of my boys produced it
is that code for slept with cause i'll
cry in accounting studio right now
it's yo chill man ain't even like that
my new music is dope though i [ __ ] with
it
i'm gonna go outside real quick grab my
sweatshirt i'm freezing
that's your best friend yeah
you ain't [ __ ] no
[Music]
hit the [ __ ] ground [ __ ] what
hit the deck white lightning this ain't
no gang
i'm in the studio with devante [ __ ]
devante this ain't no red neighborhood
cuz
what's up with that shirt you trying to
say something right here no bro the red
wings are two-and-oh it's the playoffs
right now
[ __ ] hockey it's a great sport you'd
love it for white people
no way man are you kidding pk subban's
one of the greatest players in the world
he's black
i totally dig the gang culture i know a
gang is just a family
take that [ __ ] shirt off cuz
it's just a game
that's the only color you got i'm a
loyal fan
i grew up outside detroit so i still
have criminal friends
everybody's got one criminal friend they
grew up with you know what i mean you're
never shocked that he became a criminal
he's that guy that would take a regular
prank too far when you were a kid you'd
be like hey man let's throw eggs to the
neighbors then we could toilet paper the
tree
we'll soap the door he's like hell yeah
then we'll kidnap her fat dad
come on bro i'm 11. i live alone
and girls you love them girls it's your
fault girls love bad boys
they're like he's so mysterious you're
like no
[ __ ] he's slow he's a mystery to himself
he's like what's on his mind dust
there's nothing on his mind
[Music]
should i come in [ __ ] no it's raining
well listen i appreciate you doing this
i remember you from the open mics you're
super hilarious i always heard you had a
side gig going
this isn't my world but it's my buddy's
non-girlfriend's birthday party i'm
gonna need all the [ __ ] details now
just do me a favor
put the money in the bucket last time i
checked drug trafficking and still
crying this guy
the chef brought this back from ecuador
i'm telling you guys a [ __ ] genius he
goes down there for baseball bats and
maka powder he comes back with pink
cocaine and cacao
[ __ ] love the guy he's a savage i met
him in [ __ ] the halfway house
you were in jail with the guy [ __ ] no
he's the chef he used to come in on
tuesdays cook for one of the mob bosses
you know
all right well listen man i appreciate
you you're a funny dude if you ever need
help in comedy maybe we get you some
punch-up work you don't have to do this
so much but
larry you're the man you shut your
[ __ ] mouth i'm riding up with the
names
there's nobody here man i'm in the rain
freezing are you [ __ ] kidding me
they're all over the place google's got
a drone dedicated to it
hey be careful with that [ __ ] all right
i gave some of my girlfriend before she
started singing the national anthem
she wouldn't let me leave the house i
thought it was [ __ ] iron things let
me tell you something buddy if you ever
wrote down half the [ __ ] that comes out
of your mouth you'd be a huge comedian
maybe you should get into a different
business
let me know yeah i'm telling you write
that [ __ ] down bro
you gotta go [ __ ] yourself was the weed
business legal here yet
that's an excited yes
what a racket it's a great rack you ever
going to dispensary they got 900 kinds
of weed
right you walk in they're like ah
the hippie dude behind the thing is like
what do you want to feel bro you want to
be able to read out loud
you want to stay awake all night you
want to dream in color
you want to dream in black and white you
want to [ __ ] your cousin's wife how do
you want to feel bro what do you want to
do
you want to cuddle with your dog what's
up
i just want to get high man
now you can't even smoke weed because
the weeds too powerful you get high now
you just start cleaning
i clean i'll clean a whole club i'll
start a maid service i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll clean all day and you never clean
anything you just straighten it out so
it looks better you're like yeah my
whole place is feng shui now
bam look at that look at that angle
it's like whatever happened in the old
25 bag dumb dumb weed
remember the regular weed just get high
go to taco bell spend 13
for yourself
you walk in you tell the cashier i got
13 player tap me out
[Applause]
i'm gonna do this together i don't know
what i want it's taco bell everything's
great here nothing's bad
there's nothing bad on your menu get
yourself a tostada you seem like a good
kid
you come back from taco bell with a
grocery bag best day you ever had in
your life
you get high and you take your food off
seriously you're like one
two i'll eat you third
yeah why wouldn't i go burrito supreme
third
i'll be right back i'm gonna put on a
robe and no socks
it's like the greatest day you ever had
what do they put in taco bell you ever
go to taco bell think this is the best
restaurant i've ever been to
i'm like i don't know if i'm eating a
burrito supreme or [ __ ] in hawaii
this tastes exactly the same i'll sleep
here
the hell is in taco bell i don't care if
it's not healthy
i'm not on a diet i live in l.a
everybody's on a fake diet
no carbs bro no carbohydrates all i eat
is steak peanuts cheese and guacamole
yeah bro guess what your organs are
shutting down while you're talking
my body's like dude i feel great bro i
feel lighter i feel athletic
i don't know what that is man that's
just right here
i'm fine bro my calves are ripped i'm
definitely gonna get that checked out
i think it's just a carotid artery
situation
we're so stupid we don't know anything
we try every little every trick there's
no trick no one's getting out
you know what i mean i know people that
died of cancer at 40 i got an uncle
70 weighs 480 pounds you know what i
mean cancer could be inside him like yo
i can't get past this brick of cheese
i'm trying trying
we don't know all we could do is keep it
healthy
i quit going to the strip clubs that's
my new it's my new thing i'm done
every guy does the same [ __ ] i'm not
spending more than 80 dollars
six trips to the atm later you're
robbing a friend
and every dancer is putting herself
through college i didn't realize there's
a wave of genius strippers in the world
in 10 years you're gonna be at the
neurosurgeon like pussycat johnson
holy [ __ ] you really did it
let's get a little sun
how's it going
yeah we'll talk later excuse me
oh i was just saying hi what's going on
hey how are you
good thanks good i'm mike i live in 301
just right here
it's my spot right by the pool
i figured i'd come out here you know get
a little sun
do you always lay out in your jacket no
i just figured i would go to the gym
after this
stretch it out i got a game tonight
a little ball game you pro
well not pro i mean there was there was
a time when i was you know i thought i'd
be pros
you know the family didn't really back
me on a jewish family
wanted me to be a lawyer no
i'm not a pro slow-footed white boy
how about you i used to be an olympic
fencer
are you serious yeah a long time ago
it's way too hard on my body
i could see that you know i just i look
at your body and i'm thinking you know
what give that thing a rest
rest that body i got regrets
i wasn't dated a terrorist i'm not sure
yeah dated a girl from another country
we were watching cnn
this whole thing on isis came on i'm
like [ __ ] these animals
she's like everybody does what they have
to do i'm like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
what does that even mean are you with
them mom
how you feeling you moving around on
that cane well i
the walker was more comfortable i'll get
there i'll be fine it's just a little
frustrating did the doctors even say
what the stroke was from well
first they thought it was afib then they
said it was a clot who the [ __ ] knows
your brother's gonna end up killing me
before another stroke does
where is rob let me talk to him right
here yo
what up brother remember when you come
out you're 39
the kids are 12 and 14. and mom we're
bringing you down to 68.
for a [ __ ] sake stop lying about your
age oh it's way too late i've been lying
to everyone
why do you have to lie about my age this
affects the whole family trust me
i can't have you guys running around
here with the wrong ages you're
ridiculous
i spoke to cara by the way mom listen to
me
when we broke up you were supposed to
break up that's how this works okay we
all break up together
you really screwed that one up i'm just
saying settle down for god's sake
all right listen i love you i'll talk to
you later all right i love you too
love you you still [ __ ] it up love you
my excellent yorkie
it's not cute you notice like being six
two walking a four pound dog
it's like being the last one in the
neighborhood to know your gang
there's no cool way to walk a yorkie
that's just two [ __ ] walking down the
street together
come on [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] shut up and
keep your head down talking dog
[ __ ] little fake animal everybody in
l.a brags about leaving home
you ever meet these people that brag
about leaving me oh man 17 years old i
got in the car i drove across country i
did it myself
yeah you know what's harder than leaving
home staying home
you ever stay home where you're from
it's [ __ ] hard
trust me everybody in detroit's got a
tougher life than i do
you know what i mean my brother runs a
construction company trying to put his
kids through college
i [ __ ] took two naps yesterday
yeah no i double napped all right you
ever double that
[Music]
one nap just rolled right into another
nap
the nap pro it's not difficult
okay yeah my brother's up at 5 30 in the
morning trying to put out floods and
fires
yeah i slept with an asian instagram
star two weeks ago
you know what my stress was i wasn't 100
sure it was a woman i wasn't 100
it was 86 she had a great face
heavy hand what a heavy hand [ __ ]
with the hand on the shoulder you don't
know where that comes from what do you
find a professional boxer
i can't do it i thought i could box as a
kid i took boxing i'm going
to learn how to box first thing that
happens in boxing is you look
unbelievable outside the rim
outside the ring i was one of the
greatest warm-up fighters of all time
i can hit the speed bag get heavy bag
talk to the bag what's up [ __ ]
[Music]
right i got in the ring with an opponent
i was like a gay 8th grader
what are you so mad at
i was terrified
[Music]
sarah we need to start like a business
together okay like we're [ __ ] ceos
you know
i love everything you're saying and i
love the way that you're saying it like
the determination behind your voice
yes my dad my dad can fund it right
because he's always telling me that i
can be
anything that i want to be and that i
should just pick something that i love
i barely know you but you are like
[ __ ] awesome
seriously it's crazy how you can meet
someone and in like three seconds you
know that you're supposed to be friends
for life
right now thank you so much for inviting
me no you guys should get involved in
real estate while you're at
let's flip houses why do we love crazy
because crazy's good in bed
crazy's great in bed the worst the
childhood the better the sex
i'm sorry that i know that you sleep
with a girl that never met a real dad
shit's going down
you come out of the bedroom you're
missing a tooth you got a black eye and
your foot's broken
orphanage [ __ ] it's unbelievable
god i wish i didn't say that mike i
appreciate this gesture but it's a party
bus
and we're going to go it's a little
excessive no hell no these things drive
themselves you're on a party bus buddy
this thing could end up in vegas or
morongo casino i want to meet your
daughter
maybe mom dad i'm not right hi it's me
yeah i'm just calling because i miss you
and i love you and mom so much and i was
just calling because i wanted to run
this idea by you that i think you're
gonna love give me a call as soon as you
get this
oh my god oh it's three in the morning
where you are hey mike
do you think we could get some more coke
if we need it i mean not that we do oh
[ __ ] did i not hang up yet you're a
beautiful girl in los angeles just put
your finger to your nose cocaine just
falls out of the sky you'll be good
you said i was beautiful how amazing is
mike
i appreciate you man thank you i'm sorry
i dragged you into this i'm a fool
this girl won't even talk to me if she
ignores you i'm gonna bring over three
girls to the table i'm gonna tell them
you are the heir to a railroad fortune
but i'm not andrew unfortunately what
the [ __ ] are you a history expert you
don't know what you are
nobody does man i went on 23andme i
found out my family did all kinds of
[ __ ]
i might have money coming in from a
wheat field in poland and i might have a
piece of corn from a russian
neighborhood
yo buddy thank you i got you bro you
ever talked to somebody on cocaine they
always want to start a company with you
i never met a more motivated group of
people
what the hell is going on man i'm not
starting a company
oh it's all about real estate go from
the garden you can face my [ __ ] hand
on 47 i'll walk him i don't give a [ __ ]
he punched me in the stomach what do you
feel what's your name where's my goddamn
wife
where is she what's your name
my name is i like weed better quit
spitting on me
mike can you get my friends in she's
outside and she forgot hardy
i don't own gold you said you owned a
piece yeah i own zero the smallest piece
you could possibly own
oh my god you're like a gummy bear with
tits you're so adorable
let's get some alcohol okay mike get my
friend she's hot
i know she's also got my favorite pair
of boxers
you're kind of hot yeah you touched me
again no put you in a [ __ ] chokehold
yo babyface donny osman are you [ __ ]
nuts you don't put your hand on a girl's
ass post movement bro
coming in here with a tank top fit for a
baby with hairy arms halfway up that's a
double code violation we should throw
you out just for the hair that's coming
out of your neck and that's my boy's
girl
i'm nobody's squirrel might okay yeah
dude you're old as [ __ ]
old as [ __ ] i'm 39 years old light on my
feet bro you said you were 38.
you're 43. i'm all the ages you don't
smack ass post movement buddy we don't
do that anymore
you smack somebody on the ass that's a
friend of ours we take your father's
company
my father's dead yeah so is mine so is
mine
you don't see us acting up sorry about
your dad he's probably looking down on
you right now going why is my kid
wearing a tank top
you get to stepping pal mike what are
you doing what am i doing
you're acting [ __ ] crazy i am [ __ ]
crazy i got cocaine in my fingernails i
don't even do cocaine
i got a manager that wants to be on
camera talent stevie puts the whole
party together for you and you just
ignore him
i'm going to [ __ ] stevie's brains out
later okay it's fine don't worry about
your friends just worry about yourself
all right let me just turn this into the
best party i've ever heard of [ __ ] it
in my head bad mom you're on ma if you
got kids god bless you all my friends
have kids now everybody's kid's a genius
why is everybody's kid a genius can
anybody just admit it [ __ ] it reading's
not his thing
it's okay if your kid's not a genius my
dad was not making things up about me
you know what i mean how's michael doing
in school [ __ ] he's in school
i haven't seen him in two weeks
i've seen smile i'm sure sonny some of
you have smart kids
but it's weird man my buddy's kid is one
he's one
my boy's like look at my kid bro he's
analyzing you
oh is he i'm sorry i thought he was
drooling on his foot
you look at the kid it's like he's
humming bubbles ah
he doesn't even know i'm in the room
there's no way your kid's a genius bro
you're his dad
i've known you too long i know some of
you have smart kids
i got a nephew 12 years old smarter than
me and knows it
it's like he's making fun of me in
public asking me questions i can't
answer
it's like uncle mike how come the moon
is there oh [ __ ] why is the moon there
i don't know that's where god threw it
google that [ __ ] don't embarrass me at a
picnic
you know what i know we're on the same
reading level
i wish i was great in bed every time
i've accepted it i'm amazingly average
i don't care because every now and then
i'll have an olympic moment i don't even
know where it comes from
every guy does the same [ __ ] what did i
eat today
i gotta start off every day with crunch
berry and advil
that was some kind of chemical reaction
this is the new viagra mix it in a bowl
this girl got me to try viagra i don't
know what she's like will you be my
guinea pig
i was like yeah i'll risk a heart attack
and blindness let's go
i got nothing to lose let's see what
happens when one eye shuts
i don't care [ __ ] my elbow let's see
what goes down
i don't care if one foot is numb let's
do everything
what the hell is in viagra that [ __ ]
works
i was in the kitchen having sex in the
living room
man that [ __ ] should be illegal
i was making eggs and love i don't even
know if i was there
just cooking and [ __ ] i don't know
and you have sex on viagra you get a bad
attitude oh you just think you're the
king
yeah guys we do i started yelling out
commands that don't even make sense
i was like yeah you know what just
happened part my hair
wash my pinky talk backwards now
[Music]
everybody's afraid of alone time
everyone's afraid to be alone don't be
afraid
i don't mind my alone time you know i
mean i treat me great i watch a movie
sip tequila make some food
[ __ ] it i'd take me out i wake up in the
morning i got my own phone number i
called me
what are you doing nothing you feel like
hanging not tonight i'm getting to know
me
do you have a toothbrush
[Music]
fellas we thought we had money we didn't
we realized the cost of living wasn't
high the cost of pretending ruined us
it's all right though fellas i got good
news personality's making a comeback
it's the year of personality trust me i
got eight jokes in a honda accord i'm
sleeping with everybody
fun's the new money we had so much fun
she forgot we didn't eat
she's just home hungry and happy
i wish that was true what a week
i barely got into my own show i played
men's league hoops and i had to leave
early
i met a great girl who came to my
apartment and refused to leave
i almost got killed for wearing a red
shirt in a blue neighborhood let me tell
you something
being single is exhausting and dangerous
hey you're a comedian right i've seen
you at the
comedy store mike young yeah i'm a
comedian
i also direct but nobody knows cool i'm
jenny
i just moved in here jenny oh
4b jenny 1a mike
cool yeah
god bless you new york
[Music]
what's up mike young yo what's up jason
any word
yeah i spoke to paul's money guys i got
great news
beautiful yeah [ __ ] ain't gonna happen
how was that great news
you know one door closes six more open
it's just mother nature at work you know
that [ __ ]
look at this some research and they're
looking for some diversity or something
you know
tough time to be a straight white male
mike young that's great man
keep me posted you know i will mike
young
[Music]
did find time to read your script and
it's fantastic it is very good
unfortunately
you can't afford me so um i pass
but if you ever get some money i'd love
to do it and i think i should play
somewhere
more in the range of like 38 to 41.
range because good luck with that pal
did you just hang up
[Music]
about three in the morning you gotta
shut the [ __ ] up bro
not just being nuts i don't want you to
get thrown out you know what i mean
i don't want you to get thrown up i'm
trying to save you
jesus i know i'm in a tough time but i
think i got back up
this is a tough time i don't like the
fight man i got a skinny neck
[Music]
you